this hairstyle who wore it better me or
the tilda swinton impersonating our
backup what's a hit us a joke so many
bad for the past few weeks mondays on
this channel have been episodes of not
too deep my audio and video podcasts and
as of right now we have wrapped up we're
calling season one of not too deep we
finished mark douglas last week and
we're going to be shooting some new
episodes in January which really excited
about because I think we have some ideas
and how the structure the whole project
a little slightly differently that I
think you guys would like a lot better
however I did since it is the last week
of the year and we didn't have a podcast
set for it I recorded my own podcast
made by myself which was hilarious do
you want to listen to a girl you know
you're watching me talk by myself for
some reason recording the podcast by
myself was a lot more difficult than
doing this because you don't always need
words to fill but when you're recording
only sound you do need words to fill
space and time and so it was kind of a
struggle but I wrapped up some of my
favorite moments that you guys suggested
to me it from all of the episodes those
basically like a podcast clip show but
it's really fun and then I answered a
bunch of questions that you guys
submitted to me
you can go listen on itunes or on
soundcloud the links will be in a
variety of places one place down there
show right up my bird they thought that
I would do that for this video as well
we're doing a girl fashion QA Thank You
Jess on me
questions and axles I went to a Facebook
page that's right apples I'm back on
Facebook facebook.com slash Grace public
is that my actual thing yes that is my
facebook page so go over there and check
it out and give it a like thing that's I
forget how Facebook happens ask you guys
for questions over there and now I'm
going to answer some of those questions
Jason Horton sup and then ASL
Claire Nelson thoughts how dare you post
this photo with no link to an Instagram
that I can go follow this is that's just
Katrina
Carolyn Holmstrom favorite type of pie
nachos destiny heart describe 2014 in
three words or phrases AHA describe 2014
and three words or phrases this is hard
to do on the other end that's what he
said
boom of cannon but stressful wonderful
let's keep going Jordan alia Robinson
did you ever switch majors in college I
start in the fall and I'm indecisive yes
I started undecided in college and was
also extremely indecisive I didn't know
exactly what I wanted to be which is
totally normal
I would say give yourself some time to
experiment kiss all the genders and all
the things and then think about like
what makes you passionate on a brain
stimulating economically poignant way
what makes you happy that can also make
you a living hey that's some
vlogbrothers talk for you right I don't
know did it what Lexi Cole well top five
most exciting moments or moments you're
most proud of in 2014 I haven't really
thought about this so I don't know how
accurate this answer is going to be
these are in no particular order like a
beauty pageant doing our no filter show
in the UK was really a really great
moment this year the whole halo say
experience with mamrie was a really
great moment that's - I bought a house
as an adult and that was crazy 3 I wrote
her number one New York Times
best-selling book which still feels so
insane the last I think really exciting
thing is that I feel like I've really
tried to surround myself with really
positive awesome people and it's been
awesome to watch my friends have success
and do really cool things it just is
it's the most motivating thing ever so
that's five great done it's getting too
deep Tyra Bergstrom weirdest thing
you've purchased from the internet
I bought a texador made hamster but
Xander Weibull will this question be
enough Gabriella
Riviera Target or Walmart I love Target
it's a bull's-eye for me right Toba
Ellen Begley where am I going to be on
New Year's Eve help it doesn't matter it
really doesn't matter
I think people put too much stress on
having to be at a party or be doing
something cool as long as you are
feeling good and having fun whatever
you're doing great also you don't
necessarily you don't have to have a fun
time
sometimes New Year's is like I'm
reflecting on lots of things that have
happened and maybe they're sad and so
maybe I'm bringing a new you're feeling
sad dare you could you could also just
not feel anything
my doula Robert James Potter do you
prefer to Facebook Twitter or tumblr for
fan interaction haha well what an
interesting social media makes Christian
I'm gay
to use in facebook obviously I love
Twitter and I did love tumblr I think I
checked tumblr more than the other two
because I also am now getting into
snapchat oh wait is it going it's now
it's going you guys are in the snapchat
great we did that guys and if you follow
me real bears hope I got in snapchat
maybe you saw that if you didn't follow
me then it's gone because it's gone that
for 24 hours I don't know if I like
snapchat snapchat makes me very very
anxious every time I use it but I think
it's cool you can scribble on your
photos whoa
Mac out it what's the weirdest drink
you've ever had probably this year in
the not too deep episode with
sprinkleofglitter
Louise and I played a game in which the
loser had to drink of random concoction
of a bunch of different gross alcohols
or liquids and I ended up losing and you
can go watch an episode it was it was
really fun but it was so gross and I had
to shoot two more episodes of the
podcast later that day that was at like
11:00 a.m. huh Vanessa tam what are your
new year's resolutions my new year's
resolutions are to continue to create
things that make me very happy and that
hopefully make you very happy too
don't dye my hair brown got it destiny
Clayton what do you currently smell like
I smell I think like if someone farted
in a balloon and then like put that
balloons in swamp for a little bit and
then took out a swamp and then dry in
like really really intense heat and then
open the balloon after something like
that limb yawning will you come to Asian
your people are here too I would love to
go to Asia invited me Asia also I'd love
to meet Lady Gaga's french bulldog named
Asia she gives it French manicures and
has it where pearl necklaces this took a
turn Harrison Bates the best gift you
got for Christmas and
it was from what was the best gift I got
for Christmas and who was it from
I had to spend time with people I enjoy
Who am I kidding
it was a selfie stick it's like a good
what this is what I'm using this for
there you go that is the end of this Q&A
thank you guys for watching thank you
for asking questions if you like this
video like it participate leave a
comment subscribe we're so close to 2
million subscribers on its grace and it
would be just based on how you to start
this channel at the start of this year
to end the year at least start the new
year passing 2 million subscribers would
be so cool so if you haven't subscribed
please do that and if you want to listen
to not too deep the episode that I
posted today it's on soundcloud and
iTunes and a variety of other places so
I encourage you to check that out as
well other than that I don't know yeah
you don't have to decide the first like
2 years of college is doing gen Ed's
anyway your your just taking all of the
random classes that don't necessarily
add up to the major you want so utilize
that figure out which of those classes
is really cool for you and then go home
drop out of school just start a YouTube
channel thank you for my sweatshirt Josh
Sundquist
go get his book Adam damn